[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
enlace norteamérica esta vez desde la
multicultural nueva york una ciudad que
refleja perfectamente la cantidad de
extranjeros que cada día se mudan a
vivir a eeuu según el cis en inglés
center for immigration studies este año
se bate récord jo más de 47 millones de
personas que se han trasladado a vivir
aquí la mayoría de ellos con estatus
legal en flash 24 hemos querido saber
cuál es la situación en la frontera cómo
están las cifras de inmigración ilegal y
también nos hemos querido acercar un
poquito más para conocer la política de
inmigración que está aplicando el
presidente joe biden y cuáles están
siendo sus consecuencias
[Música]
uno de cada siete personas que vive en
este país ha nacido en el extranjero lo
que representa más del 14 por ciento de
la población norteamericana es la cifra
más alta de inmigrantes viviendo aquí en
los últimos 112 años
javier senior de colombiano y vivo en
nueva york yo vengo de valencia españa
el informe del cis destaca que los
primeros 16 meses del gobierno del
presidente joe biden la población total
de eeuu nacida en el extranjero aumentó
en dos millones curiosamente el doble de
lo que creció la población nacida en
esta nación
países que tienen una población más
envejecida como eeuu y otros países
occidentales sabes donde la población
tiene más edad necesita en mano de obra
y luego tienes los países emisores como
méxico india república dominicana que
tienen una población en crecimiento más
joven sin tantas oportunidades laborales
y ese desequilibrio natural obviamente
va a empujar a la gente a moverse en
busca de empleo
el cis asegura que hay cerca de 11 35
millones de indocumentados en este país
un 13% más que en el 2000 1 pero casi
los mismos que en el 2019 lo que indica
que nos acercamos a los niveles de
inmigración ilegal que había antes de la
pandemia según el instituto gallup la
mayoría de la población estadounidense
ve la inmigración como algo bueno pero
la crisis en la frontera ha provocado
una gran división entre republicanos y
demócratas
las personas indocumentadas se están
convirtiendo en un arma política en este
país en cuanto llegan a su territorio el
gobernador de texas greg abbott las mete
en un autobús y les envía a ciudades
demócratas como washington o nueva york
dice que con esta acción quiere
presionar al gobierno de joe biden para
que asegure la frontera el problema es
que lo está haciendo sin ningún tipo de
coordinación entre las autoridades y las
familias que quieren quedarse aquí nos
aseguraremos de que obtengan el refugio
adecuado pero estamos descubriendo de
que algunas de las familias que están en
el autobús querían ir a otros lugares y
no se les permitió hacerlo incluso es el
caso de esta familia salieron de
venezuela hace más de un mes cuando
cruzaron la frontera de manera ilegal en
texas los metieron en un autobús con
dirección mayor bajo la promesa de que
aquí cuidarían de ellos quien te dejo
eso haya inmigración que en nueva york
hay más posibilidades de que me ayuden
es como yo no tenía quien me recibiera y
luego de una travesía infernal en la que
incluso atravesaron la selva llegaron
aquí hambrientos y heridos me resbalé
una piedra y
me fui a agarrar y me fracturé la mano
de momento tienen un hogar temporal en
este refugio mientras rehacen su vida
algo que no está siendo nada fácil ha
conseguido trabajo hoy
porque
[Música]
la gran manzana lucha por alojar a la
avalancha de inmigrantes indocumentados
que el gobernador texano está enviando
se ha declarado ciudad santuario pero lo
cierto es que los refugios están
saturados y los recursos no dan abasto
el alcalde ya le ha pedido ayuda al
gobierno central en el otro lado está la
migración legal que aquí es mayoritaria
eeuu es uno de los países que más
migrantes acoge en todo el mundo cada
año la mayoría de ellos vienen de méxico
seguido de filipinas india china y
vietnam entre los cuatro suman el 44% de
la población extranjera que hay aquí y
uno de cada tres vienen del país azteca
por eso hay barrios como éste donde
prácticamente parece que estemos en
mexico los anuncios están en español y
su gastronomía ha invadido las calles
los mexicanos ahora la mayoría de los
nuevos o hasta la pizzería son de los
carteles de las iglesias en español
también como en los colegios y en la
mayoría de los negocios se escucha esto
no necesita ni hablar inglés creo que no
porque ya lo mismo blanco ya hablan
español casi cada vez ganan más terreno
en la calle y en el empleo el gobierno
de méxico ha confirmado que su país
recibirá este año un récord de
356 mil visas de trabajo estadounidenses
desde el pasado mes de octubre la
patrulla fronteriza ha interceptado a
cerca de 16 millones de personas en la
frontera la mayoría de ellas mexicanas
los republicanos aseguran que con la
eliminación del título 42 ese programa
migratorio de donald trump conocido como
quédate en mexico estas cifras
aumentarán sin embargo los defensores de
los inmigrantes creen que eeuu vuelve a
su esencia los nuevos casos de asilo que
serán procesados como siempre fue antes
dentro de los eeuu es un regreso a lo
que es en realidad este país que es un
refugiado para las personas que lo
necesitan esta abogada nos cuenta
también la nueva apuesta del presidente
estadounidense una tarjeta de
identificación para migrantes
indocumentados conocida como tarjeta de
expediente seguro y básicamente con ese
documento los individuos los inmigrantes
que entran pues cualquier oficial
federal ahí va a poder ver el nombre de
la es un número de caso su próxima
audiencia si la persona tiene un caso
vigente si la persona tiene una orden de
deportación o expulsión hasta aquí
nuestro programa de hoy si desea verlo
nuevamente puede visitar nuestras redes
sociales o nuestra página web france24
puntocom